hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor i've been investing
in property now for 12 years
and for the very first time in my entire
life
i've started a petition on the
government website because absolutely
right now enough is enough they are
trying to
ruin property investment in london which
will have a devastating rippling effect
across the uk
siddique was saying that if he gets
re-elected as mayor
he's going to bring in rent control and
he's going to fight
for the right for him to be able to
dictate
how much rents can be charged now we've
seen this happen before
in places like new york and it's
devastated
the entirety of the housing market i've
been to new york
and guess what there's so much
homelessness in new york
the rents are ridiculously expensive the
tenants are unhappy
but no one wants to invest there because
it's been ruined
because of this exact same policy rent
control
so siddique said if he's re-elected he's
gonna try and bring rent control in
he's been re-elected enough is enough
so i've started a petition on the
government website it's been it's been
approved
and i'm not gonna let this happen and i
don't think you should either
so we need to stand together now because
this is getting ridiculous they're
trying to ruin property investment
there's already ridiculous things
they've brought in
crazy ludicrous things they've brought
in which are making it really hard
to be a property investor so we need to
get really creative
but rent controls is just one step
too far so please stand with me
not with me for yourself for your fellow
investors
for your tenants for your children for
everybody
let's stand together and not allow this
to happen because it's happened in other
places
they trialled it in scotland and it was
an absolute shambles and the scottish
government even said
that it was a flop um they did it in
berlin and now there's a massive
shortage of houses why because no one
wants to build in an area
where rents are going to be capped so
it's going to bring homelessness
it's going to it's going to just distort
the economy in the housing market
and now they're trying to do it in
london and we know that in in england
everywhere follows london and if this
happens in london not only is it going
to ruin london but it's going to have a
devastating
rippling effect so what do i want you to
do about this well i have spent an
awful lot of time uh speaking about this
and putting together this petition it's
finally been accepted
uh and the government have now made the
link live and if we get to
10 000 signatures it takes 20 seconds to
sign
but if we get 10 000 signatures the
government are then gonna make
make a stance on it and hopefully
hopefully if we make ten thousand
signatures there's already
within the first hour of it going live
without a we've had a hundred signatures
now we've only got a limited time period
to do this in six months it'll be
scrapped
if we don't get this signed right now in
six months it'll be scrapped
so whether you like me whether you don't
like me whatever you think of some of my
other videos if you
are a tenant or a property investor
you need to sign this petition you need
to spread it far and wide it will take
20 30 seconds to do it you just have to
put literally your name and your address
and stuff
uh press submit and then they'll email
you confirm the email
boom done and your vote counts most
people
agree that rent control is a terrible
idea and don't want to see london
devastated like this
they won't bother to take 20 seconds to
sign the petition so every time someone
signs
the government will see it and they'll
be thinking okay with one person signed
that's probably 2 000 people's opinions
okay so you need to be a leader right
now and you need to sign the petition
i'll leave a link
in the description uh if you do nothing
else today
sign the petition to stop sadiq khan
having authority to be able to dictate
rents the rents are already capped the
rents are already dictated
by the tenants and the marketplace
if you if you're a landlord you can't
just charge what you want for your rent
you can charge you can only charge what
it's what people are prepared to pay
we cannot have the government
controlling
the marketplace like this not in
property
not on my watch let's not let this
happen you can bring change sign
the petition enough is
enough